In the last video, we showed you a piece of land,
right in the middle of our land.
This land is actually not ours...
Yeah, it's weird, but we will use it anyway,
because we have trust in the local people!
So, we cleared up some areas, to see what is there...
And, we found a lot of old abandoned ruins,
that we could later renovate.
Everything is now cleaned up around the ruin!
Small room, bigger room!
But, this will require some paperwork first.
So, to start, we're going to build
a movable house on an old trailer.
And, we're going to get one right now!
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
All right, so, we're currently at a place,
where they sell a lot of trailers, vehicles, random stuff...
We're going to see if we can find a trailer, I guess?
It could also be a truck.
They also have some fridges, but I don't know...
We're just going to have a look around
to see what they have
To see what would be a good base,
to recycle for the house.
Let's check it out.
So, here we have one from the circus.
I think they used to sleep in here?
It's very thin metal and uninsulated
It could be an option, and it seems like a good size.
But, let's see more!
Another one here!
And, another circus container!
Another option is an old big trailer from a truck.
This is way bigger than we need it,
but we could potentially cut it at size.
So, we have the length we want,
which is also an option and maybe remove a few axils...
Because, we don't really need them.
Or, we just buy a smaller trailer
like this one here,
Which is more around the size we're looking for I think,
like, 6 meters, not 12 meters.
So, that's also an option.
I see an another circus one with a cooling box inside?
Looks a bit raw.
Another option is these cooling boxes,
which they use to transport things.
They're already insulated pretty thick, which is nice.
This one is a bit small,
but you will also have higher ones.
It's also been nastier to work with,
with all the fiberglass and stuff...
But, it's a decent option since we are
looking for a well insulated thing.
So, it might be nice to recycle one of these things?
Not sure.
Maybe, we should renovate this pickup?
It's a Hilux.
What do you think about renovating this pickup?
- I see a lot of potential in this vehicle!
It could be a next project!
I could also get one of these things.
It's the same size as a shipping container,
which would be, I think, the appropriate size for us.
Which could give a base frame to build upon.
He also has a lot of yarn!
I don't think we need it at this point, but maybe...
And also, tires, which he has a lot of too!
So, we just left this place.
You have many interesting vehicles and trailers,
but apparently, he had another place somewhere close by!
With some old army vehicles and trailers?
We're going to check that out!
- So, this guy what he does apparently
is to buy broken companies?
He gets everything and they have!
Machinery, which some parts
are crap, and some parts are solid...
Some parts: he modified and fixed!
He plays around with their waste a bit.
- How is the pickup driving?
It's amazing!
Are we in trailer land?
- You'll find many funny things!
We walked around to see what we could find.
So, here we are, at the second place!
It has much, much more than the previous one!
Let me actually show you some drone shots,
to really see how many there are!
So, this place looks pretty impressive from above.
It's full of old scrap metal, trailers, and vehicles,
with a some sort of a big, dug-out mine next to it.
Overall, it looks rough.
Looks like some things have been there
for many years, and rusting away.
Waiting for a new owner!
It's actually nice to see places
like this still exist.
That people see value in reusing these things.
If not, they would melt them into
another metal objects or sent to Africa.
I don't know if you can see it from this camera...
In here, it's full of trailers, trucks, vehicles, bread boxes...
Many cool structures, actually!
So, we're going to have a walk around,
to see if something fits.
They have the super nice trailers with a big plateau.
So, it's a good base that the other one
didn't have to build up on.
However, you still need to build all of this on top.
So, it would also be cool,
if we can find more of a box...
Because, that means we can just recycle more materials,
instead of having to build something new here...
Here, you have one with a box on top,
which is kind of a good size for us actually!
I'm not sure what used to be inside.
It ould be anything...
So, we're going to have a look...
Looks raw.
It looks like a toilet.
Showers and a very soft floor...
It's a very rough box, and a bit dirty...
Like, it's all this fake wood that got wet,
and expanded, so it's not really solid...
So, let's continue!
- This could be maybe our next pickup!
Look at this interior!
Nice temperature!
Another cool one!
This one is much higher than usual!
Four meters or something, I think he said?
Which is also the problem...
You cannot drive it illegally on the road, or something.
So, it's been here for 20 years.
It used to transport bread in France,
which is kind of cool.
So, we could potentially make
like a double floor or something in it.
And, it's a lot of space!
It's a bit rough...
Some old trailers!
They used to move animals in.
Also, it looks like a potential a good house.
But, it might stink too long...
A horse box?
Let me show you!
And finally, we have one last one
we saw here from the Army.
I think it's like an old trailer,
for the telecommunications or something?
Sick military stuff!
Los Angeles, California.
Well, cool stuff inside, but not very useful.
But, it's cool!
- It's a cool place!
A difficult choice...
- And, you are hot...
Oh yeah, I am hot!
So, that's it!
We see many trucks, and it's getting very warm now...
It's time to go.
We're not going to share yet on what we're going to pick!
Because, on the one hand, it's cool to take something
for so many years old, very worn out and really revitalize it again.
But, it's also rough to do it on the land,
because we don't really have a proper closed space...
So, the moment we start sanding it, or cutting it,
all the paint would blow away into nature.
We don't really have a very industrial area.
We want to pick something that is more recyclable,
that is older and rougher, and find a way to properly renovate it.
Or, start a bit cleaner and simpler,
and built more natural on top.
We're not sure yet, and we're going to think about it!
Let us know, if you have any thoughts,
or suggestions on where to go for!
But, for now, we're going to digest
and think about all these cool things we've seen!
So, we're now having some lunch,
to think about which trailer we want.
Like, writing down the options.
- We don't know what to do.
We tried to make a big list, but we still don't know...
How are we going to decide this?
What are you thinking, Dave?
- Maybe someone else would know?
Who is 'someone else'?
- A whole lot of people, and maybe all together,
they would know the best option...
Where do we find them?
- Not in here!
So, me and Adrian went to visit a scrapyard.
We started looking into different kind of trailers,
and boxes that are on top.
We couldn't decide, so we figured you guys can decide,
on what house we're going to build.
So now, on Patreon, you can vote which option we should go for,
and we'll pick whatever comes out of the votes!
Kind of scary to do, but yeah, I hope is going to be okay.
So then, we made a poll on Patreon.
We like to include more people through the decision making process,
because we feel this project is for everyone!
So, this seemed like a good try-out!
We had five different trailers, with each having their pros and cons.
And, the winner was...
A pig trailer!
We're currently here to actually buy it.
It's in a very rough condition.
And, as you might have seen, but you chose it anyway!
Which means: a lot of work for us...
So, the guys of the scrapyard brought the pig trailer.
They delivered it to the land close by,
because the yellow truck cannot go on our bumpy roads...
For that, we need a local tractor.
We actually also needed to prepare the Middle Land.
What do you think about it?
- Rough, but promising!
All right, so, we're currently in the Middle Land.
We can come here by walking
a few narrow pathways between the bushes.
But, in order to bring a trailer here,
there's not really a route for that...
And, not that size, at least, because everything around it
is fully overgrown with mimosas and brambles.
So, we need to make that!
But, it turns out it's not that easy...
So, we need to figure out
where are we going to make it.
Let me show you what our options are.
All right, so, just as a reference,
we're currently here in the Middle Land.
We have our Basekamp right here,
and a big bottom grass field is here.
So, on the Middle Land, we had this ruin that we discovered,
and this big middle terrace.
Which is actually lower than all the other parts,
but this is where the trailer needs to go.
Now, there's no route to go there with a big vehicle.
It's fully overgrown with mimosa,
so we need to make it.
We have two options:
A route from here, which is the shortest one,
so it seems like it makes sense.
Or, a longer one right here,
which is coming from Basekamp.
Now, the shorter one seems nice,
but it actually has a few downsides.
Let me show you.
So, the biggest downside is that
there's a big height difference here...
This is quite a steep wall!
Actually, in the winter, a lot of water flows here.
So, it also erodes the land.
The road is there, where you can see the little pole.
If you want to drive here with a truck,
we need to fully cover this with dirt, so we can drive it.
Which is a big operation...
And, it probably will flush away in the winter,
due to the water stream here...
So, I was just down there.
This is the road where the truck would need to drive.
Which is also a bit of a downside,
that this road is quite narrow for a steep turn there.
So, it would be kind of a difficult maneuver,
to turn in a trailer here, to down there...
Let me show you our second option!
The second option is right here.
I'm currently near Basekamp, which is behind me.
The road would need to be here!
No real sign of a road yet, but the main upside
is that there is a road here, here and here.
So, I'm currently at an intersection!
Which should make it easy for a big truck,
to maneuver and turn around.
The big upside is also that there's
no big height difference here, when you go down.
It's just a slow slope,
and it's a bit of a lengthy one.
We need to make a curve in there,
But then, we would arrive in the second terrace.
So, this should be a bit more chopping work,
but much more easy to access later on!
I think we're going to go for this option,
and it also has a lot of little mimosas...
And, over here, it's quite dense with a lot of
very young, thin mimosa sticks.
We're going to use this sawblade on the brush cutter.
I rarely use this, because it feels a bit rough,
but it also seems for this purpose it's quite suited!
It just quickly chops a lot of small, little sticks.
So, let's see!
So, you might wonder:
''Isn't it bad to chop down all these trees?''
Let me explain your situation with this little oak right here.
This oak is a native tree from here,
and the trees around me are invasive trees called mimosa.
And, they grow fast, like, really fast,
and much faster than this oak.
The downside of that is that they take all the sun,
from this little oak tree that wants to grow.
So, it's a very dominant species,
and it makes it very hard for this little oak to survive.
By cleaning up the mimosas,
we get more chances of survival for the native trees.
We hope it helps the ecosystem here also,
to create a bit more of a resilient forest.
So, we're going to keep all the oaks we see,
like all the native trees, and only clear up the mimosas.
Right now, we are about one-third in.
I still need to go to there...
Almost there...
Now, we have opened the path
for the trailer to come, but not really...
The road itself is still very rough...
Some more work to do.
All right, so, now everything is chopped!
A lot of stuff on the ground.
Next up: clean it all up.
But, it's going to be a lot of work...
So, I'm going to get some help
After removing all the trees,
we called a local friend with a digger.
To help us remove the roots,
to make sure they don't stick out.
Hopefully, the mimosas don't grow back fast.
They're currently cleaning up all the mimosa roots,
and really leveling the soil.
Just so that the pig trailer can come.
We're currently here in the Middle Land,
and the trailer is going to be here!
Now, finally, we can move the trailer to land.
We're not sure if the brakes still work,
and the road is quite narrow and hilly...
So, we put the digger in the back,
to make sure the trailer doesn't drive over the tractor...
How'd it go?
- Smooth.
Very smooth!
So, here we have the trailer!
Very beautiful!
There's some new back lights for transport.
It's on the land finally!
Nice!
Let me show you a few things!
First off, it's blue.
As you might have seen.
There's a handle here, of which I have no clue what it does,
but it turns surprisingly smooth.
So, it feels like it's been used.
A bunch of cables to connect.
No idea what they mean...
Looks a bit rusty, but I guess we don't need them!
There's a few small cosmetic holes here and there.
Not much profile in the wheels.
Looks like a go-kart or something.
Yeah, it looks good...
Here, we have a box.
I have no idea what's inside...
I never opened it.
It's a bit rusty!
Wow!
No, it has nothing...
Besides a stone.
So, yeah, here are a bunch of things on the bottom.
I think we could strip it out,
because I'm not going to use many of that...
I have no idea what any of this is.
I recognize the wheels.
So, here we have the beautiful inside.
Yeah, what can I say?
It's a little bit rusty on the edges...
Also, the wood is a bit rotten...
And, the roof doesn't really exist...
I mean: it's something...
You wanted this, Patreon!
There's some dividers in here.
It's pretty good!
It needs some paint...
Some holes in the floor.
This thing looks a bit like a prison!
As you can see, it needs quite some work,
but it's a pretty nice, big size!
So, we're not sure yet what we're going to do,
because you want to reuse as much as possible.
But, overall, the underlying base is pretty solid,
and the size is also pretty good.
It's like a nice box to build something in.
So, we're also going to start the design, work and planning.
Like, how do you want to arrange the space?
We are thinking of dividing it,
so we have some sort of a bedroom area.
Where we can chill, and maybe a wall with a door.
You have more of a little kitchen,
and a place to relax
A door there...
Maybe thinking of replacing those,
with a big glass window.
But, overall, the first rough work that needs to be done
is to clean it up, and to see the damage.
Then, insulate the walls, build a frame, build a roof on top,
and then we can start on the interior.
If you're interested to help out working on a rusty trailer,
you can still sign up below!
You kind of need to be fast,
because we're going to move fast with this project.
But, yeah, if you want to follow it,
make sure to subscribe!
Or, continue supporting us on Patreon,
if you want to vote another time.
Like, when we are going to buy a rusty thing like this...
Thanks for watching!
See you in the next video!
- Wait! I forgot to say something very important!
Yes! The next video is going to be update 88!
So, it means: a challenges video!
We will talk about past and current challenges,
and also we will do a Q&A.
- So, don't forget to ask your questions in the comments section,
and we will try to answer everybody!
Yeah! See you in the next update! Ciao!